قال امدها تعيش حرب روسيا على جارتها
الغربيه نهايه شهرها العاشر تقديرات
متشائمه تشير الى ان الاسابيع القادمه
ستكون حاسمه في القتال اما نهايه الحرب
فبدت لها ابعد من اي وقت مضى ليس تماما
يرد القائلون بان الحل بيد الرئيس
الامريكي
للتحدث مع نظيره الروسي بشان خطه سلام
تنهي الحرب في اوكرانيا
روسيا بازاله قواتها وسحبها من اوكرانيا
القرار بيد شخص واحد بيد رجل واحد
الرئيس قال انه راغب ولديه يتحدث الى بوت
كذلك ونحن نعتقد ان الدبلوماسيه هي السبيل
الى الامام
لا تبذ الامور بهذا اليسر فاحاديث التفاوض
تترافق دوما مع اشتراطات الاطراف المعنيه
بها تلك التي تحاول على الارض قلب الكفه
لمصلحتها بما يعزز موقفها التفاوضي
لا تنزه كيا بنفسها عن مسعا من ذلك القبيل
لكنها تعمل على بلوره ما تسميه مبادره
سلام عالميه تريد ان تلتف حولها جهود دول
العالم لانهاء الحرب
في الوقت الذي تكافح فيه اوكرانيا من اجل
السلام ولا شيء غير السلام ندعو العالم
الى قبول الصيغه سلام نعرض هذه المبادره
لانه لا يوجد ابطال في الحرب ولا يمكن
تحقيق تعادل لذلك اعلن مبادره لاحتضان
صيغه سلام عالميه هذا الشتاء من اجل توحيد
كل امم العالم حول قضيه السلام العالمي لا
سلام ممكن هنا دون محاوره موسكو هكذا يقول
المنطق كان رئيس الاوكراني قد شكك قبل ان
في مجاعه عرض الفرنسيه للوساطه في حوار مع
الروس قال حينئذ انه لا جدوى من اجراء اي
محادثات اذا كانت ستتوافق مع رؤيه الروسيه
حسره
لكنها باريس واشنطن ايد تاه لاحقا خطه
سلام طرحها رئيس زنسكي وكذلك فعل
الاوروبيون في عمومهم دعم اولئك لمبادرات
السلام لم يمنع استمرارهم في تصليحكيه ولم
يحل دون اقرار حوزمي عقوبات متلاحقه ضد
موسكو لاعاقه قدرتها على تمويل الحرب
والحرب يفهم الروس انه حلفاء اوكرانيا
الغربيين يتحولون كل يوم اكثر الى اطراف
فيها وذاك ما قد يبطل في رايهم اي مسعا
جدي لاحلال السلام